access bird wait what am I supposed to
do something about that is that
pertinent information for my everyday
life
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to dead space Oh cargo
bay right over there
I'm going this way
bomb
I don't know how the hell I got dumped
over here uh but everyone is very happy
with me ah
oh good
everyone is so thrilled everything's
working out wonderfully and nothing is
going to go wrong at all
ever
in Forever do I even have any side
objectives I don't even think I do
I'm pretty sure I cleared them all out I
still don't know what that stasis thing
did but
I don't know but I gotta go to the
thingamabob
the thingamabob the whatchamacallit go
watch them who's
ah hello
Mr Clark we're approaching the hangar
Bay we'll meet you there with the marker
why am I shaking my head
we'll send the hive mind back into the
darkness
okay
so glad you gave that guy our only
Escape shuttle
[__] Isaac
those things you've killed their biomass
was pulled down on the cargo bay it's
recommined itself in tune
well it's something huge and the markers
embedded right in the middle how the how
do we do this I've got the instruments
cargo cranes they can move half a bay of
mining gear no problem if whatever's
down there wins The Vessel for the
marker I'm
override the safeties and yes it might
work but hurry we're losing critical
systems fast
okey dokey uh that doesn't sound good
um
what did you just say all the things
I've killed all of its biomass is kind
of like what to be and why am I so chill
about this it's cause I'm so goddamn
cool but uh something about me the Mimi
that is listening to this I don't feel
too cool about this
that's fine emergency all Personnel
procedure designated safe Zone
immediately
oh that sounds fun
um I like saving
hello ah bench oh you you weren't um
boom
it's stupid it was a marker talking to
me poof yeah nothing
I can't see oh my God you know I'm okay
oh god well that was nauseating
but oh well
all right buddy
come at me
come at me Bros
you don't got your unkillable
monstrosity anymore it's all me all the
time excuse me I'm sorry pardon me it's
all me all the time all day
oh it's gonna get me I got it first what
is this what do you got here
security cost Force Gun upgrade wow if I
use that that'd be super cool
it'll be so rad
oh my God so many goodies why are you
giving me so many goodies
why are you why I don't know if I like
this
[Music]
hmm there are a lot of goodies around
here
I feel like this is real hello
oh
uh
oh got it without popping it
that's good
thank you I'm loading up I'm just gonna
load up before I do anything because if
they're gonna give me this stuff I'm
Gonna Take It
not that I'm in desperate need
here you go okay
sure all my guns are reloaded they are
okay where am I going
to engage the cargo crane uh
uh retrieve cargo sure
may be delayed
delayed how much
how much delay we talk in here
[Music]
wow oh they're different guns didn't
think that that's what I had equipped
all right beginning retrieval oh you did
it oh man that was quick
still
as one might say still so very whole hey
wait a minute
no
thank you
access bridge is instructing transfer
access break wait what am I supposed to
do something about that is that
pertinent information for my everyday
life
didn't seem good
oh you're not oh yes yes
bridge is obstructing transfers yeah I
gotcha okay which one that one
oh no that one
um
when did you get there
foreign
easy man I love the plasma cutter it is
literally the best weapon in the game
there's there's almost no reason to use
anything else besides those little
crawly dudes that's about the only thing
that I can imagine that's gonna get the
jump on me
hello
goodbye
oh that's behind me
whoa let's just hold on a second here
let's hold on was that something else
behind me
okay hold on
it's trimmer yeah yeah yeah
whoa what the baby hell
it's like when those things are near the
marker they they glow
fascinating
oh my God it's a note I missed
what the hell did I miss that
oh no I didn't never mind I'm reading a
cargo transfer to the hangar Bay the
marker
on our way kind your flight path goes by
airlock 19. I can get there from the
computer core the pickup yes we'll be
there
into the airlock come on
no movement on the cameras
I'm gonna run for it
wish me luck good luck
you're probably gonna need it
all right hanger Bay
all's well that ends well and this ended
well
can't wait to go home
ah don't worry Nicole
it's almost over
we're gonna make it out of here
alive
both of us
I don't think that there's anything else
[Music]
yeah yeah I know all kinds of bad stuff
going on all the time here ammunition
capacity got 140 beautiful bullets ready
and willing I still haven't found the
other upgrade for this I must have
missed it somewhere
have been pretty obviously
skated right past it but it's my least
favorite gun so
[Music]
the containment field what are you
containing
[Music]
oh oh no no no hey oh am I out of
bullets
you still not good
he's still not dead
lucky you died by a save point but you
couldn't get to it fast enough idiot all
right hanger Bay
hanger baby
go
it just don't cut limb too good
you just don't do the limb cutting very
goodly
[__] is my brother on the monitor he's
right by the airlock
Place get to you Kendra we're out of
time I
take it out there
I can make it if I run
we're all losing it
We're not gonna lose it yet
we're almost there
we're almost all together
whole in one place
soon we will all be able to hold hands
in the cargo hold oh
quarantine activated I missed this
oh Hammond you made it
[Applause]
wow something's getting real goochy
around here
foreign
how are you still alive
you are nothing but bones left
well alive is a you know questionable
thing but still standing
ta-da
I did it
I'm the best it was no
God it would be crazy if there was like
a uh
no there was definitely not anything
over there all right
down where I originally ran way at the
beginning of this game I
like Runway too
that's helpful
sure is dark here
anybody hiding anything behind here
foreign
we're all gonna hop on here and we're
gonna get out
we're safe
I can't run the automated loading
controls must be the damage to the ship
we're losing time the hive mind is down
there behind relax I'll turn off the
gravity in the hanger then I can load
the marker by hand all right
don't worry Amelia they understand
Jesus ah seems fine to me
anybody heard from Nicole hey buddy I
got word from Nicole uh
I haven't heard a peep out of Nicole in
a little bit so um
get up there
hello
oh my God this guy's no word
hmm I thought I was faster than this but
I'm not
a what
I landed on nothing all right track
control
okay oh I remember I think there's uh
yes
I need to open
the doors
hello doors
there are a marker in here
no why is there no marker in here I feel
like there should be a marker clearance
whoa
what Peng hang an oddly intriguing
artifact from the past sell at the store
for credits
goddamn diamond
well damn good thing I opened this door
I mean considering how important money
is for sure for sure
um here
yes
ah oh there she is
there she freaking blows I can only
assume that that's gonna be needed
something
all right don't worry guys uh all under
control
all handled
you guys gotta grab a few things
it can wait we're making good time here
thank you
come here beautiful oh never mind
hey no baby's allowed
shut up all right all right I said shut
oh really
that's what I thought
um oh track controller is offline you
are right about that
then we simply Mosey it along until it's
turned this way do I need this is this
battery gonna like pop in the middle of
this ordeal
just have a funny feeling about that
hey
stop that
I said stop that
another baby
there's a baby baby
I see oh baby
why are you still standing I exploded
you to a hearing back
what you're not dead
hi
oh I didn't get to
baby
maybe they do glow when they're near the
market oh you're tough
there it is
I need to restore gravity hurry
what is this for this feels like it's
for something
yeah I wouldn't want the benefit of zero
gravity to lift something very heavy
into a ship
it's on Ford come quickly go open the
hatch for him
I can't okay
all right I'm on the way we got this
teamwork DreamWork
yes
friends is she here
oh no
[Music]
sorry Isaac I couldn't trust him with
the marker Kendra what are you doing
when my department sent me here to do
even if the Valor couldn't help me out
like I wanted apartment who are you I
work for Earth gov cleaning up a very
very old mess
I told you and him in the age of seven
was off limits
the planet was one big government
experiment
the marker this Divine artifact
it was built by human hands
possible it's an alien world the miners
tug up the [__] thing after it was
planted here a few hundred years ago
even kind didn't pick up on that
they found the first marker in some
crater on Earth
that one that was real
alien
enough to inspire unitology
our people studied it and reverse
engineered this red marker
but they needed somewhere to test it
ages seven
you've seen the result
of nightmares
I thought the old reports were just
Hysteria
until I saw
what I saw
they sealed off the whole system buried
the records nice and clean
until CEC got greedy
those idiots tore each of seven apart
and woke up with the old research team
left behind sorry to sweeping all under
the rug Devin we have to return the
marker if anyone else stumbles across
ages seven it was disappeared once we
can do it again
I've seen how the marker [__] with your
head
it must be contained
for what it's worth
we made a great team
you'll find another way after ishimura
I mean
you're one hell of an engineer
Daniels
well you know I am a hell of an engineer
I'm so worried about this it's okay
maybe maybe
not the worst idea
Isaac come in it's Nicole where are you
in the flight control room please you
have to come up here now
there's still a way out for us but we
don't have much time
oh you're so right I bet I need this
I definitely need this
[Music]
I need it Nicole
it's special to me you wouldn't
understand
oh
God oh my God oh
God hello
anything up
it's another weird message I don't know
what that's about
oh that symbol is the marker ah it's not
an eight it's the marker
foreign
you in here Nicole you need a battery I
brushed you a gift
I think you're gonna like it and if you
don't I'll be so upset
hello
there you are here I am
through your investigation Mercer
we don't have to stop I need you to know
I'm sorry about everything
it's okay
welcome
still hope
you can recall the shuttle and remote
pilot Premiere bring back the marker and
we can return it to ages seven
you can make us whole again I just want
to make things right
then let's do it together
okey dokey then
all right you need a battery procedures
damn it Isaac you don't know what you're
doing I know I'm finally doing the smart
smart [__] kidding me
first sg09
skateboard damn
we lost her it doesn't matter
she can't escape her fate
but who can
I didn't
are you looking at the book I thought
you're looking at the battery for a
second it's my gift for you
oh wise
Isaac
's finished off we get on that show
Leave No Regrets go
I'll reprogram the shuttle with our
flight path to each of seven and join
you on board
okie dokie so you're telling me that
there's absolutely
nothing
nothing to uh
nothing to do for coming back okay once
we go down there it's kind of down there
for goodsies
because uh
hey wait a minute this is for goodies
but you can threaten Nicole you son of a
[__]
all right that's what I thought
fascinating
I don't think there's any other things
that I need to get on board
I got that weird prototype stasis or
whatever I don't know what to do with it
but there's no other side missions there
were those weird puzzle things but um I
might just leave that for greater minds
than myself
still don't know
it just feels important feels like I
need it
I don't know why but I feel like I need
it hey wait a minute hey you you're
threatening my battery you're trying to
get my battery
get away from my battery
get away from it oh
my battery
all right so long as no one's trying to
blow up my battery
very important
I don't think am I forgetting anything
I don't think I'm forgetting anything
battery oh
man that's really foreboding
I don't have any side missions I think I
did everything
pretty sure I did there might be a few
like weapon upgrades that I haven't
gotten but nothing that I'm gonna like
super regret not getting
I don't think anyway let's do this I'm
going
me and my battery
Nicole watch out for the batteries
it's in the way
I should have put it in a seat
I never doubted you Isaac
are you ready
we're together again
nothing can stop us now
this isn't how I imagine saying goodbye
to the issue around
I'm good
are you afraid Isaac no
you I can handle any
[Music]
one more ride together then
this all began in a core of the planet
Daniel said earthguff built the marker
some experiment they abandoned hundreds
of years ago
[Music]
lovely jumps forward in time
how convenient these headaches
[Music]
if you're not ready
hungry
it'll try to eat Us Alive
we'll put things back the way they were
okay
a fascinating
I've never really fully understood this
kind of like love hate
thing about the marker and the
Necromorphs like it's both there to like
repulse them but also it's beneficial
but it makes it happen but it doesn't
it's it's strange right where's my
battery
no
no up
[Applause]
Dead Space
can't believe it
oh hi Nicole how'd you get down there
well we'll have to end this one here
thank you everybody so much for watching
and get ready for what might just be the
conclusion of Dead Space
in the next episode
bye-bye